However, a few things have solidified
that I am going to show the DM
interaction between us more than
anything. It's the DMs are very
embarrassing for him. Bald old man
emoji, person running emoji,
uh puff of smoke emoji. It is like it is
like the most subhuman like narcissistic
selfcentered thought process you could
imagine. at minimum does not give a
possibly deliberately engages this way.
Guys, today I was expecting to be
starting the stream with a debate with
Hutch. Okay, former perhaps future
Destiny Orbiter.
Okay, former perhaps future Destiny
Orbiter.
as Hutch saw a video I made on him just
the other day, a segment that I put out
where I reviewed a few of his debates.
He saw it and uh he decided he wanted to
debate. He decided he wanted to talk to
me. So, he tweeted at me just the other
day. Hi, we should chat on stream
sometime.
See, this is 20th of July. It is now the
the 21st. This was about 48 hours ago
almost. But anyway, Hutch tweeted this
out and lots of people very excited.
Okay, lots of people are excited. Lots
of people were saying they were they
were happy to see Hutch debate uh
debating me and so I replied obviously I
replied saying sure feel free to DM or
add me on Discord
and so that's what happened. Hutch DM'd
me and we were going to we were setting
up a debate for today for right now
really for like five minutes ago it was
meant to start
but that didn't happen.
Now, I was initially hopeful. I was
initially quite hopeful. I was like, I
don't really have like these huge
political disagreements with Hutch. You
know, ultimately we're both we're both
lips. Uh the issues I have are stuff
like uh the the constant hand ringing
and about how Mro Gaza lefties uh did
didn't vote enough. That's totally why
we lost the election, guys. Or they
weren't enthusiastic enough about the
DNC. That's why we lost the election.
It's just not true. I can't see that as
true at all. Um,
and and the
sort of game I think some people like
Hutch and Lonerbox types play where
they'll be like, "Why are people mad at
Contra?" I don't understand why people
are mad at Contra Points. She said
genocide bad. It's like, well, if you
actually read the statement, you
probably can figure out why lefties
would be mad with her really, couldn't
you? Like, she's she's expressing things
that they probably wouldn't be okay
with. And like the whole point of the
the statement was basically, yeah, maybe
this all this pro Palestine protesting
just isn't worth it. Maybe you should
give it up because you got Trump
elected. That's basically what the point
was. So,
I don't like that stuff. But that's
about it. That's like the end of my
substantive disagreements with Hutch.
The rest is a lot about his personality.
Um, so I thought maybe we could talk
about that. I was initially hopeful.
Initially hopeful. I thought he was
going to watch my video. Um, that's and
that's not unfounded either. That's not
just me being like, "Oh, yeah, I'm sure
you should watch my video." No, I I saw
this getting shared around. So, this is
actually from Nicholas Dioro's paid
Discord, I believe. Um, and it's a
screenshot from Hutch's Discord. So,
Hutch says in his Discord, "Hey,
everyone, we've got some fun content to
react to tomorrow." So, he never got to
this. And he he linked my video here.
And uh someone in Nick Dioro's Discord
in the in the paid members Nick Dorio
Discord posts that should be a fun
watch. Lol. Can't wait for Quan to be in
chat begging to call in. Well, jokes's
on you loser because the whole point was
that he was going to debate me. So nice
one, you [__] idiot.
So I I was hopeful cuz Hutch is doing
this whole like, oh, we got some fun
content to react to.
I'm gonna own this guy. We got some We
got some fun content to react to, guys.
This this sn this snark leftist is is
attacking me basically is attacking me
for being bold. Isn't that kind of a
double standard? Don't argue against
attacking intrinsic traits. I was I was
hoping for that sort of reaction, you
know. I was hoping for that sort of
thing.
But that hasn't happened, guys. That
hasn't happened. And guys, I'm thinking
about how to handle this. Okay, I was
racking my brain for how to handle this.
Really, I started racking my brain for
how to handle this last night before I
went to sleep because I did speak to
Hutch briefly before I before I went to
sleep.
But this morning when I woke up,
especially I say this morning, this
afternoon when I woke up especially, I
was contemplating how do I handle this?
What do I do? What do I do in this
situation?
Because I don't like just leaking DMs.
Um, unless I like know the person well,
it's just like a funny inconsequential
DM and we're, you know, everyone's gonna
be okay with it. I don't like just going
and leaking DMs generally.
However, a few things have solidified
that I am going to show the DM
interaction between us. A few things
have solidified it for me. There's a few
factors that I'm considering here. So, I
want to sort of lay out my thinking on
this. First of all, I do think we need
to uh penalize running
pretty hard. I think that's or where we
can penalize running, it should be
penalized. That's number one.
Um number two is he was very cocky
initially. I don't I don't like this
attitude where you go into your Discord
and tag at everyone with a video
critical of you. I don't like this
attitude at all. I don't go and do gay
[__] like this. I don't like this
attitude whatsoever where you go and t
you tag at everyone. Oh, we've got some
fun content to react to tomorrow.
It's kind It's pretty [__] behavior.
It's I'm not even It's like It is kind
of lowkey brigading. I don't really care
about that aspect of it. It's just kind
of like It just comes off very insecure.
It's just like you're going you're
running into your Discord hug box to at
everyone be like, "G, someone's talking
[__] about me right now. Like you you
look like kind of a [__] [__] You
do kind of look like a massive [__]
[__]
Um, so I don't like that attitude. So
that's the first two things.
Now, third thing,
I've heard that he said
someone reached out to tell him about
me. Now, he didn't say that to me, so
there's sort of a discrepancy
uh between those two, which is which is
bothersome. And also, I really really
dislike this attitude of going around
behind, oh, don't talk to that guy.
Don't talk to that guy. Why? Why didn't
talk to me? Why won't talk to me? Why?
Whoever's telling you not to talk to me
should say in public why they told you
not to talk to me, what the basis is,
and then when they say inevitably he's
bad faith, they should give an example
and explain explain how I was wrong in
that case. Um, that that's what I would
like to say. I don't like this [__]
attitude where it's like, oh, don't
don't talk to this guy. Don't talk to
this guy. That's [__] [__] attitude.
And the final reason, and this is really
the most important reason why I'm
deciding to leak these DMs, um,
it's because of how he acted in the DMs.
It's because of how he acted
more than anything. It's the DMs are
very embarrassing for him
and that's pretty much the deciding
factor here.
Um, so I want to I want to go over
these. Okay guys, I'm going to talk
about Hutch a little bit more as we go
over these.
Dev SFO in chat says, "I have only one
impression of Hutch. We were on some
panel together. He liked what I said and
did that soy snapping thing. Did not
believe it was a real person.
You might feel that again in a moment,
Dev. You might feel that again in a
moment.
Okay, so
let's just have a little look at what he
said in these games. Let's try and line
these up well with my with my camera.
If I can get my trackpad to work and do
a little zoom.
right now. No such luck.
There we go. There we go. Okay, so we're
going to go through and analyze what
happened here. So, Hutch reaches out
after my Twitter reply and he says, "Are
you free tomorrow? I'm available from
9:30 a.m. Pacific until around 1:00
p.m." Okay, good start. That's That's
cool. Now, I'm not available at those
times. I usually start uh stream at
about 1:00 p.m. Pacific. That's usually
the the earliest I'll start stream at is
1 p.m. Pacific. Usually more like 2. So
that that's not really very good for me.
I say I'm not really available to stream
until at least 1 p.m. 1 p.m. Pacific
most days. Are you freeing you later at
some point or is that your limit? Can
try to sort something out. You I'm
trying to be accommodating. I'm trying
to make sure this happens. Trying to,
you know, make sure that even if there's
a problem on his side with the time, he
knows. He knows I'm here. He knows I'm
I'm willing. Okay.
I have a thing tomorrow, but I can do 1
p.m. Pacific on Monday. So, obviously
the thing he had that day was was a wick
panel about Israel Palestine.
I understand you had a pre pre-booked
wick panel. I understand don't know me
getting away your wick panel. Like
seriously. So,
so I say you good with 1:30? That's more
like my usual start uh stream starting
time. I'm like, okay, I need to that why
I get make sure I've got time to like
prep and not prep as in prep for the
debate, but you know, prep for my stream
and be ready, be be awake. had my
coffee, all that stuff.
He says, "Sure." Okay, great.
Nice. I assume you do debates over
Discord. I'm just creaming on there. And
I follow up with, "Let me know if you
want to limit it to specific topics or
anything like that. If you want to
debate something in particular or just
talk through disagreements, I don't
mind." So, I'm trying to lay out here,
if you've got specific terms you want
for this debate, specific topics you
want to go touch or don't want to touch,
tell me now. Let's let's have that
discussion now so that when we have the
conversation there can't be any
confusion. No one can be like I'm being
ambushed or any crazy [__] like that.
Not that I think Hutch would necessarily
do that, but just, you know, I'm trying
to I'm trying to make sure we hash
everything out before we start the
conversation. Just make sure we're we're
perfect. We're perfectly set. So,
he says, "Discord is fine. I figured we
would debate my boldness and general
cringe shitness in response to your
videos. Okay. Figure this is joking.
Figure he's just like, you know, we're
[__] around here. You know, we're
debate his boldness. Yeah. Haha. Epic.
You know, like, sure, no topics. I guess
you haven't watched my video yet. You're
just like posting it in your Discord
because you're like, "Oh, someone's
hating on me. Guys, come check out this
person hating on me." You don't even
know what was said in it yet. You're
asking to debate without knowing the
criticisms. You might agree with them
fully, but you're you're just going for
the debate. And I like I just don't get
it. Like he was doing sort of like a
weird posturing thing, but he doesn't
even know what was said.
Okay.
So, so I leave it there. I don't reply
to that. I'm like, "Okay, this guy's
like, you know, I guess no specific
topics." I leave it there. I don't I
don't know what else to say to that. You
know, it doesn't seem like we've got any
specific topics, so we'll just go on to
the debate.
So, but he messages back
later on. Okay, like 24 hours later, he
says, "Wait, so you're like a [__] lord?
I initially thought you were interested
in politics. I have absolutely zero
desire to do [__] lord stuff."
So, I don't really know what he means by
this.
I don't know what a [__] lord is. I
think the last time I heard [__] lord
would have been in like 2013
listening to yogcast videos where they
would use [__] lord as a porative.
That that's like about that's that's
probably my last memory
of someone saying [__] lord.
So there's like this. So, now I am I am
trapped in DMs with this 40-year-old man
using the term [__] lord, and I've got
no idea what it means. I'm like, I don't
know what you're asking me. Can you talk
like a human being, please?
But furthermore than that, he he says,
"I thought you were actually interested
in politics." Now, if you just glance at
my channel, my second channel, you can
you can very quickly see I am interested
in I put out stuff on politics all the
time. I like talking about politics.
I like joking around about it as well. I
like making fun of people and and
ripping on people's content while I'm
talking about politics, but I definitely
touch on on politics quite a lot. So, I
don't really know. So, I'm either So,
we're drawing a distinction here like a
there's like a dichotomy between people
who are [__] lords and people are
interested in politics. You can't
apparently you can't be both. I I don't
know necessarily what a shitload is, but
I'm understanding that in Hutch's view,
these are uh uh in a dichotomy. You can
you cannot be both. You're either a [__]
lord or interest in politics. So, I'm
like trying to figure out exactly what
I'm being asked here. I have absolutely
zero desire to do [__] lord stuff. It's
like you're laying down pretty firmly
here like this is actually this this
doesn't feel like you're really asking
me a question here. You're not actually
asking me if I'm a [__] lord or whatever
that means. You're not actually asking
me that. You've decided you don't want
to do this conversation anymore and you
are now trying to come up with a way of
asking me a question
that will give you the pretext to to
back out without actually revealing the
reason you're backing out. Right?
Because obviously I can have a
conversation about politics. You just go
glanc at the video that I watched that I
that I put out about you. You could just
go see what say maybe strong takes are
in there. That's about politics
obviously. But you but you didn't but
apparently you didn't do that. Um so it
it does just come come off as like uh a
little bit disingenuous to me. I'm like
okay. So I say no idea what you mean by
that. I mainly cover drama and sometimes
politics/adjacent topics.
You talk like a human. Please don't talk
look talk look talk look talk look talk
look talk look talk look talk look like
a person please explain what you mean
so he says shitload stuff not serious
memes
there's there's
stops there [__] lord stuff period not
serious period memes period
you mean am I going to troll you like
what's what are you asking right Now
he's very he's a very serious guy,
Hutch. Okay, listen. Destiny adjacent
political commentary is serious business
and and Hutch takes it as such. Okay,
it's very serious business. Do not don't
engage with any [__] lords, okay? They
just they bring down the rep. All right,
we can't we can't make it seem seem
unserious by engaging with [__] lords,
okay? I'm I'm going I'm going to be a
part of the DNC one day. I want to be I
want to be a canvasing organizer one
day. I want to have my own canvasing
house where I can invite a bunch of
college kids to to stay for six weeks.
This is very serious. I need to look
after my reputation.
Could not possibly care less about that
stuff.
So So I say that's not much clearer to
be uh Jesus Christ. That's not much
clearer to be honest. Are you asking if
I actually give my opinions? If so, then
yes.
I joke around a lot. Also, if that's
what you're asking. So,
I thought I'm getting across pretty well
here. I'm like, yeah, there's like a a
joking kind of comedy vibe all the time,
some of the stuff I'm saying. But I I
I'm giving opinions, you know, they're
in a direction. I'm giving a take. I'll
justify it. I I'll argue it.
And he says, "Your content is a bit too
[__] posty for for the kind of
conversations go with God." Sorry, I'm
[__] up reading that, but it's not
actually my fault because he does say,
"Your content is a bit too [__] posty
for the kinds of conversations. Go with
God." Salute emoji. So now it's not just
Okay, so this is like I was really like,
"Okay, I'm going to show these DMs cuz
this is just crazy. This is crazy, bro.
Get off your [__] high horse, you
self-s serious bold [__] loser.
You're [__] [__] You are so
embarrassing saying [__] like this. Your
content is a bit too [__] posty for the
She means these these kinds of
conversations. Go with God salute, dude.
Shut the [__] up. What do you mean my
content is too [__] posty for these
kinds of conversations? Asmin Gold is
the biggest commentator on the [__]
internet right now and you would jump at
any opportunity to debate that guy. No,
you've come you've got some other [__]
excuse to not [__] talk to me because
Aeronite got in your ear or some [__]
like that and you've decided you're not
doing it because you're worried about
how it might go or how it might look to
your friends or some [__] like that and
you're being a [__] [__] now.
You're too [__] posty for these kinds of
conversations. Get a [__] grip. Like
it's not even like it's it's too [__]
posty for me. Like I'm trying to be more
serious. It's for these kinds of
conversations, bro. Get a [__] grip.
It's the internet, bro. You're a 500
viewer internet politics streamer. It
ain't that [__] deep, bro. It really
ain't that [__] deep. Okay, it really
is not.
And so I reply
and this is He doesn't reply to this
running. And I do uh bored old man
emoji, person running emoji, uh puff of
smoke emoji.
So that's where that's where
communication ended. Okay, that's where
communication ended. Now, there's
interesting other dynamics happening
here, guys. There's some interesting
other dynamics happening here. There's
some interesting dynamics
I think we need to unpick. So, first of
all, I think the audio is a little bit
[__] on this clip, but we'll play
anyway. Hutch said this yesterday.
I've been thinking about the Destiny
situation a little bit more, guys. I've
been thinking about that that situation
a little bit more.
I don't regret distancing myself from
something that was very radioactive.
Like every creator has to consider their
own reputation and their own
like brand.
Um that's not
>> so he says he doesn't regret what he
did. Every creator has to consider their
own brand and persona whatever
reputation.
He doesn't say anything about the
morality of it. Does it say anything
about oh this being something disgusting
this guy did to my friend Pixie that I
was just I simp I just can't can't
abide. No, it's the the optics and the
the reputation and the PR. Okay.
>> Not a moral calculation. It's just
that's like a necessary calculation that
every creator has to make. But I do
think I regret
like talking about it in detail.
I think looking back I wish I would have
just put that space and just not talked
about it
but it is what it is.
>> So he wishes he just quiet quietly left
instead of making such a big deal out of
it. So let's have what did he say back
at
>> you know I originally I originally
>> you know I originally I I originally
>> also the reason why this is happening by
the way is cuz he had he had two debates
recently that went pretty poorly for
him. He had a debate on Live and Learn
where they brought on these guys called
the Vanguard. Now, one of them was
really dumb. One of them was slightly
less dumb. But Hutch wasn't really like
he keeps saying, "Oh, I I won against
him. I won against them." The real
challenge to Hutch in that conversation
wasn't the Vanguard guys. It was Pisco
and Josiah. Pisco and Josiah were
obviously trying to sort of steal man
the position of the Vanguard guys to
Hutch. and Hutch was shutting down and
not engaging and looking pretty
[__] Now, Destiny went and looked
at that debate and obviously sided with
Hutch against Pisco and the Vanguard
guys because Destiny is on this Pisco is
a communist. He's trying to discredit
Pisco a lot right now. So, he's just
like blindly siding against him trying
to like, you know, he sees Hutch as his
his way of influence against these
people, I think. So, basically, Hutch
has totally absorbed that and he has
convinced himself now he actually didn't
look [__] in those debates. In fact, I
actually watched for like all of maybe
30 seconds. I clicked on his Destiny
stream because he was reviewing another
Hutch debate because Hutch had a
follow-up conversation with Josiah and
Pisco today. Well, well, he didn't have
it today, but Destiny was reviewing it
today. I saw like 30 seconds of it.
Basically, Pisco is making the point
that
Democrats don't communicate their wins
well. and when Democrats aren't
necessarily winning but are expending
all their options. So for instance with
the student loan stuff where Pis
obviously argues that Democrats like
expended basically all their reasonable
options to try and get the student loan
forgiveness through in the maximum they
could. Um
but Pisco still says that as much as
they did do everything they could to try
and get it through legislatively,
they did not successfully communicate
that they were doing everything they
could to voters.
I don't think that's particularly
controversial, but Destiny heard that
and Destiny freaks out and goes, "Yeah,
because of people like you at Pisco."
Like legit, you can go watch it. Because
of people like you at Pisco.
It's absurd to say it's because of
people like Pisco. And the justification
he's using for that is that people like
Pisco are pushing that message that the
Democrats are so useless. Pisco doesn't
push that message. Pisco acknowledges
that the people who feel that way feel
that way for a reason and it's because
of the Democrats poor communication. But
Destiny immediately goes, "No, it's
because of people like Pisco. Maybe the
media," and he says this, "Maybe the
media should do a better job of of of
telling people how the process works."
Yeah, you're going to change your whole
[__] country's media. Bro, that's
much more difficult than changing your
candidate. And he cries, "Oh, I don't
want an influencer candidate." Well, too
bad. That's what the rest of your
[__] country wants and you have to
win elections, you [__] idiot. It's
just like the absolute dumbest
responses. But Hutch obviously because
massa destiny, massa Steve is saying
that he's right now. He's going to
incorporate this and allow it to just
totally like re reshape him again and
harden his resolve in the most like
[__] direction that only serves this
[__] come eating deadbeat [__]
cult leader. Like that is the only
person that serves. is politically
[__] but it's just really good for
making people not like Hassan and like
Destiny and [__] like that. That's like
the only it's the only thing that
attitude serves is is is that basically
that's why he does it is to try and
distinguish himself from other other
lefties and left leaning lips online is
he'll go, "Oh, they're all [__]
They they just hate Biden. They just
hate Biden every time anyone has any
criticism." It's he does that with
Israel. He does. It's always just trying
to be in like this counter lane. Anyway,
not the point. Not the point.
Let's get Let's just see what Hutch said
here.
So, a chatter says it's not that big of
a deal. Why are you making such a big
deal out of this? What does Hutch say?
>> She's She's totally fine.
>> What does Hutch say
>> with it? Um, she mostly just feels
really bad about this. So, this was the
text that she sent me today. Just so you
have an idea of like where I'm coming
from and that she is like agreeing. She
knows that I'm sending you these texts.
Crossman says, "All right, listening to
this reaction, I'm going to unsubscribe.
The situation being treated like it's
that big of a deal is simply ridiculous.
It's unfortunate that it happened. It's
not that serious." I just want to frame
something to you. Okay. I'm going to
assume that you're a human being that's
capable of empathy. I'm going to assume
that you're a a human being that is
capable of imagining what something
would feel like and just proceed from
there. And I want you to imagine you
wake up one day and there are nude
images of you on the internet and you
know you're never going to be able to
take them down. And you had aspired to
to to serve in a somewhat public role
within the framework of like political
engagement as a career. And on top of
being humiliated by having your images
out there on the internet for anyone to
see, now you have to consider dozens of
other ways that this could potentially
impact your life. You have to live with
the stress that some crazy internet
person, and there's no shortage of crazy
people on the internet, you have to live
with the concern that some crazy person
on the internet is going to send your
nude photos to your friends, your
family.
>> So he's saying, wait, so Hot is right
now saying, "Things have changed in the
case. I feel bad for Pixie, but well, he
should describe what's changed in the
case." Well, he should explain what
substantively has changed in the case.
He should explain that. It's very, it
should be very easy to do that
>> to
>> your parents, to your siblings, to your
employers, to your future employers. And
so the so as a result of a decision that
somebody else made without your consent
that you were not a party to, you have
to now adjust psychologically and have
the the fortitude to like go like go
through an experience like that and
still live a functioning life, which
when I ask myself that, I don't know if
I could do it. If I was humiliated like
that, I don't know if you guys would
ever see me again ever on the internet.
And then I don't know what I would do.
What I don't know what I would do for
like I would I would just have to
disappear. I would just have to like my
whole life would have to change. So I
think to minimize this situation and say
it's not that big of a deal. I'll give
you the benefit of the doubt and say
that I don't think you've really thought
this through. I don't think you really
fully considered how much that would
impact someone's internal life, their
emotional state, their mental state,
which is bad enough, but I don't think
you probably evaluate how how much it
would impact someone's external life for
the rest of their life. Something like
this, people kill themselves for stuff
like this.
>> So, what changed in the case?
>> Now, Destiny didn't do it maliciously,
right? But that doesn't matter because
of his.
>> So he never thought it was malicious. He
never thought it was malicious. So that
couldn't have changed.
>> Wildly irresponsible,
wildly impulsive, self-s serving
behavior. As a consequence of that,
somebody else's and now potentially
multiple people's lives are now possibly
forever changed. And so I I'm just
saying to me that is a big deal. So I
would encourage you if you're still in
chat, I don't know if you pieced out
already, just think about it. Just went
just think about just just imagine how
would your life change if you were in
the exact same spot. Just imagine that.
I think if you think about it long
enough, I think you'll start to
understand that this is a this is a big
deal and that what Destiny did was a
profound violation of somebody else's
privacy.
>> Wow.
>> And it had serious consequence.
>> Strong words that if there's receipts
that you want
>> Strong words. So what's changed? So what
changed about the case?
Like this guy is just a total
pathetic
[__] I would get it. I could at least
I would have No, I would have slightly
more marginally more the tiniest bit
more respect if it if I thought it was
just for money. If I thought it was just
money, but it's not. This guy is a
pathetic [__] who got his ego bruised
by his co-hosts. Destiny appeared to
soothe his ego and now everything's
flipping in his head. Everything's
flipping. It is like be it is like the
most subhuman like narcissistic
selfcentered thought process you could
imagine. It's just it's so patently
obvious. It's just blatant on the face
of it. It's crazy. Totally absurd.
Totally insane. So yeah. So yeah, pretty
crazy stuff. He just totally ran.
Do we have um can we get his stream from
right now?
>> Partisan stuff was way more common back
then and
but people like when people are like we
need we need a
>> let's run it back. Let's hear if you
said something about Destiny recently.
How a good was it?
>> Um what the hell could you possibly have
meant with the Destiny comment? I
shouldn't have
>> Okay, wait. Here we go. Here we go.
We got it. We got it right on.
>> And then he said he'll never be able to
pass bipartisan legislation. I don't
know if anybody was saying he'll never
spring us out of CO.
Did anybody hear that? I mean, like once
we had the vaccine, I was like, "Okay,
we're probably going to be okay."
We'll probably be okay. And I did trust
the administration to uh administer the
uh to like distribute the vaccine.
Um what the hell could you possibly have
meant with the Destiny comment? I
shouldn't have went into detail. What?
What? Why is that a regret? The Destiny
thing, man. Like I just wish like look
there was a lot of stuff that came out
with the Destiny thing that was like
very damning on its face. Um
>> okay so what's less damning now?
>> I will say I've not I have not I can't
tell you every single particular detail
of the case but I've kept up about
certain like things
>> have come out during that case. Um I I
still have disagreements with kind of
like turning all of that into content.
Um feels a bit
>> So So wait, so he's literally Wait, has
he just been watching Destiny's segments
and just accepting all of it? Does he
even check it against the court record?
You know, Destiny will present things as
revelations that aren't. So right now
he's pretending that he's got no idea
that Pixie sent uh the video to her
boyfriend as well. Yet, it was always
stated that they had a discussion about
sending it to significant others and
Destiny never contested the idea that
Pixie was doing the same until like a
few weeks ago. It's like, it's so
[__] crazy. Like, that was it was
always baked in. That's the one thing I
can think of that might convince someone
something's changed, but it wasn't the
case. But it's just a total [__]
[__] lie from Destiny. So, what has
changed, Touch? Please tell us what has
changed.
Um, but
in retrospect, like I think like putting
distance between myself and Destiny and
other creators doing the same, I don't
regret that at all. Um, I was distancing
myself from something that was really
radioactive and uh I did he was not like
entitled to, you know, everyone that he
ever collaborated with like a couple
times to, you know, reach out and and
and and like
>> see this is actually Dude, Dan should
actually be fulfilling his promise to
make sure that none of these rats are
allowed back on the [__] ship. Dan
should absolutely be fulfilling that
promise because this is despicable. This
is despicable. He's sitting here saying
he wants to have his cake and eat it too
in both directions. Right? He is saying
I wasn't wrong for disavowing Destiny
even though I was wrong about the case
and I should take him back now. So in
Hutch's world, in Hutch's mindset, he is
the person, he is the person in every
drama who when their friend is accused
of something, falsely accused in Hutch's
mind now, falsely accused essentially,
he is the guy in all these allegation
dramas who despite knowing it's kind of
[__] or thinking maybe it's kind of
[__] not think not having all the
details, immediately drops him and
offers a massive moral condemnation
when really he He doesn't know anything
about it and he just he doesn't actually
care about any of it. Literally does not
give a [__] He is that guy. He is the
the the archetype of the worst [__]
personality e- celeb in any [__]
allegation drama who will just ditch
their friend for [__] allegations in
his mind obviously. Yeah. Like Dean
dropping Sison. So he is just like
displaying that he is just one of the
most dis like despicable people going
with this.
be a friendctive and uh and other
creators doing the same. I don't regret
that at all. Um I was distancing myself
from something that was really
radioactive and uh I did he was not like
entitled to you know everyone that he
ever collaborated with like a couple
times to you know reach out and and and
and like
be a friend in that way. we just we
never had that relationship ever. You
know, if that was someone I knew, like
someone that was really close to me, I
would support my friend in that. Like I
would like even if they made a mistake
and even if they did things that I
thought was was bad or whatever, you
know, like I would still support. But we
never so like I you know I don't I don't
regret like putting distance
between myself and all that in the
moment. But uh I think like in
retrospect I think uh I regret like
speaking on the particulars of the of
the case cuz there
>> So what changed? So what changed? So
what changed about your initial
statements?
>> Certain things that have come out, you
know, in this trial so far and we'll see
how the rest of the case plays out. But
like
that's that's what I mean when I say
that. Um
>> bro, what does the court case have to do
with any of it? Is it not about the
underlying behavior? the court case
wasn't even filed when you when you
disavowed. Is it not about the
underlying behavior which has been
either admitted to or mostly proven
in depending on which case you're
talking about.
Uh so yeah
uh like the Willie Mac video too like I
I I I certainly regret like reacting to
that. Like I don't think I milked this
thing at all, you know? Like there were
a few times on stream that people asked
me for my opinion about things and um
you know we made a we made like a
collective like or we made like
individual statements like on the
podcast and I feel like that was the
correct thing to do at the time just to
like just say uh like we're we're going
to distance oursel. Um
but yeah reacting to the Willie Mac
video like I'll probably private that
video actually. Um
>> [__]
Okay. Well, now we have to watch this.
Now we just have to watch this. Now we
have to watch Hutch Reacts Willy Mac
video. But
yeah, you know, it is what it is.
Archive. Archive. Archive. There's still
like there's still things that I would
be critical of, but I just I just feel
like maybe maybe it's better to just let
that process play out and
we'll get more sort of information, be
able to come to like uh more fleshed out
opinions or conclusions about the thing.
>> Um,
>> dude, it's like so Say what has changed.
Say what has changed, you [__] [__]
>> Things in the case that have come to
light that made me go like, "Huh?
Huh?" you know. Um, but I also still
like, you know, I also still feel like
very bad for Pixie, right? Like that's
still a horrific thing to have to go
through. Um,
and so I
>> also guys, I haven't shielded or stream.
That was a great time to remind you,
okay guys, as we continue with this Epic
Hutch content, 540 people watching right
now, 69 likes on stream, some 4770
people. Please move the cursor to the
thumbs up and clicking or pressing a
thumbs up on the mobile device. That
would be huge appreciated. Now, if you
want to take your support one step
further, thank you for the $5, that
guy56. Guys, I thought what Destiny did
was pretty bad, but then I watched some
Destiny videos and I've changed my mind.
>> So true. So true.
>> Lots of things and feeling crazy.
>> Thank you, Max. Thank you. I should have
reset my goal on streams as well. Thank
you. Thank you, Matt, for the $20.
Hugely appreciate. Thanks so much.
Yeah, you can donate directly through a
stream link and a pin chat message. You
can also buy a membership to the
channel. Gift a membership to the
channel. Gift a whole bunch of
memberships throughout the chat. Buy a
super chat which will highlight your
message and rts
or buy a super sticker which YouTube
image or gift. It will be highlighted in
chat and I'll describe it to you. You
can go to discord.gg/quman
twitter.com/quman.
Guys, we're setting up an epic gold
colon D. Okay, epic goal colon D.
It's in the chat. Awesome. Epic goal in
the chat. Let's continue. I I still I
still maintain a very healthy degree of
sympathy for for what that experience
must have been like for her. And I and I
feel bad that she had to go through
that. Uh or anybody else who got their
[__] leaked, right?
Arch once diverted a debate about
skill-based matchmaking, Call of Duty to
Trump versus Bronnie Sanders.
Something's not right with this guy.
Okay, they $8 Max.
But at the end of the day, and this is
something that I will maintain, at the
end of the day, like Destiny sometimes
he makes it very he makes it very
difficult to like um
>> Erodite to Turkey. Tom, when I asked
Destiny if he had consent, he said
probably not.
>> Thank you for the $10 from Southside.
Thank you.
He he's just a guy that obviously loves
to like push the envelope as far as it
can go. And anybody who does that, it
can be kind of tricky to be aligned with
that with with someone like that. Um
because then people go to No, pushing
the envelope isn't really the problem.
It's the habitual sexual consent
violations that I think are the bigger
problem. Actually,
I think it's more like the habitual
consent violations.
go to you and they're like, "What do you
think of this? What do you think of
this?" And I'm not, you know, I don't
control anybody else's behavior. And
just because I associate myself with
someone, it doesn't mean that I [__]
love everything that they do. That's not
But that's not even that to me is not
controversial. Um, it's just the there
are these pressure campaigns that pop up
and people try to like tar and feather
you because of because of something that
somebody else did. And that's all very
kind of like tiring sometimes. But so
you're literally just saying you're a
[__] who ditched Destiny to avoid
controversy, but didn't believe anything
you were saying.
This is like it's so transparent. Just
stand on it like Dan. There's a reason
why Dan gets so much less [__] for his
association with Destiny than most other
people. Cuz he says, "Yeah, that guy is
completely [__] in the head. I'm
friends with him though." And doesn't
[__] defend him on every [__]
point.
He's just like, "Yeah, that yeah, that
that probably happened. Yeah, that guy
was like kind of abusive to his
ex-wife."
It's like, "That's Dan. That's Dan. You
doing this mealy mouth [__] where,
oh, I don't know, man. I feel like some
stuff in this case changed. I don't
know, man." Giving no examples. Like a
total [__]
Yeah. No one's got respect for that. Um,
but yeah. Um, yeah. So anyways, that's
you know I like I see some people going
into particulars in my chat right now.
Like the whole point was like I don't I
think it's better to just like wait like
there's nothing wrong with just waiting
just like wait for as much information
as as can come out in this way to have
like a really fully informed opinion on
the matter. Um
>> Uhhuh.
>> Uh yeah. Anyways,
>> and he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about and he's living in a
different generation and
>> Okay. Well, with that in I think that's
the end of the Destiny talk there in his
in his live VOD. With that in mind,
let's uh let's jump over to his William
Aro reaction.
>> When are the Hutch leaks coming? Listen,
I've beening shacked up with the same
woman for 10 years now. My life.
>> In my last video, I made clear that if
Destiny wanted to be taken seriously
again, he'd have to own up to what he
did. He's always preaching about
accountability, but now when it's his
time to finally own up, he doesn't.
Instead, he tells me he's going to drop
the manifesto to end all manifestos. I
was not very confident as the evidence
against him was already damning. He
literally admitted fault. Aaron tells
Destiny, "You distributed it
non-consensually." And Destiny replies,
"Yeah, I know. I have damaged her
severely." He tells Pixie, "Uh, I'm so
sorry. There's literally zero excuse."
But he tries to recontextualize this in
our interview.
>> When I sent that message to Pixie and I
was like, "Um, I feeling horrible. Like,
I'm so sorry. Like, I've psychologically
damaged her. Like, this is horrible,
whatever." I do feel horrible. It has
nothing to do with whether or not I
could send this on the video. I just
feel horrible that something that I was
involved in ended up leaking publicly.
Like even if she would have said like
even if that wouldn't have been said to
anybody, if somebody would like hacks my
Google Drive, I would have said the
exact same thing.
>> So was his manifesto good? Well, it
seems to have persuaded much of his own
community with many of the top comments
praising him. However, when you get down
to the meat of the argument he's making,
it doesn't change anything. I confront
him about doxing pedo allegations as
well as converse with people from his
past. This is the Destiny manifesto
where there's DMs about you saying like,
"Hey, I wish this person has this person
been doxed yet?"
>> Yeah, I for Anna that's [__] For
just like Queen, I'd kill him if I
could. I choke the house into it, bro. I
swear to God if I quit streaming, I'm
gonna go on an assassination mission.
Okay,
>> are disappearing one at a time. Okay,
>> that's why this video is sponsored by or
a topic where people's personal
>> will you know of all creators like
Willy's segways into his ad ad reads are
justing top tier just amazing
>> by the way.
Oh yeah, I need to make this point. This
is a very important point to make
actually. This is actually a key point
to make. This is this is really
important stuff.
Okay, this is like really important
stuff. So, you'll notice there
um Destiny actually uh uh called for my
death, said he he would he would kill
me. Uh there is actually a moment in
this video it shows Destiny attempting
to dox me as well. Obviously, I'm not
the only person this has happened to.
Now,
something a little interesting. I saw
someone tweet out
a fellow by the name of little little
Steve tweeted something very interesting
out.
Little Steve
Massa Massa Stevie
said
anything involving this bad empanada guy
or anyone that supports him is
justifiable. memo. Anything is justified
against bad empanada and anyone that
supports him. Well, let's apply those
standards. Why are we saying this about
bad empanada? Well, it appears to me
because bad empanada doxed Willy Mack's
wife.
So would Destiny be saying
that those who
dox people,
those who make calls to violence or
illusions to violence should be fair
game. And all of their supporters and
all of their supporters, okay? All the
personalities that back them up, all the
chatters that back them up, everything
are just everything against these
people. Anything is justifiable. That
seems to be the standard to me is that
anything is justifiable against Destiny
and the people who support him.
No. Is that not the standard?
That's that's what he's laying out for
me here. Now, I have principles. I have
principles. I don't think it's no bad
tactics, only bad targets. That's not
me.
But Destiny is very clearly laying out
that those are the standards that he
believes in. Those are the standards he
he wishes to be enforced is if you're a
doctor, if you call for violence,
anything is justifiable against you
supporters.
>> Order taken.
>> Okay, that's not what I'm saying, Max.
Actually, I just explicitly said
otherwise, actually, Max, but Destiny is
clearly laying it out for you. Destiny
is clearly laying it out. He is saying
this type of behavior isn't okay.
Anything is justifiable.
That's what I'm saying here.
manifesto spends a lot of time
clarifying that he is the biggest victim
of these leaks. Incredibly bizarre how
many people are fixated on insisting
that I'm not a victim in this when I was
the primary target of the entire revenge
porn posting. While other people were
undeniably harmed by these leaks, they
were seen as collateral damage to the
publisher of the material and the
website providing hosting for it in the
goal to attack me whether it was through
reputation, monetary harm, or just some
other form of sadistic.
>> I mean, I he's just right about that.
Like I don't I don't know why that's
controversial. Like that that other
people were victimized in the process
doesn't change the fact that you know
it's just patently true that Destiny was
the primary target, right?
>> Nobody is denying that you are also a
victim. Nobody is denying that the
hacker is a bad guy. But the only reason
there is collateral damage is you. If
you didn't non-consensually share these
girls images, there would be nothing for
the hacker to leak. I feel like he knows
this. He's just trying to mitigate
accountability in front of his audience.
In Dusty's video, he does provide some
background information on the hacker who
goes by the name Solo.
>> Solo messaged me sometime in the morning
and said that he was unhappy with how
the coverage of the leaks had been so
far. He felt as though people weren't
giving it enough attention, so he was
going to leak more from my logs with
Rose if I didn't allow him to come on my
stream and speak with me. I don't
exactly remember what the message he was
as I just woken up, read it, and then
responded briefly before going back to
sleep. The next time I checked my
messages with him, everything had been
deleted.
>> Luckily, I have them.
>> Could be wrong. Tell me if I'm wrong,
but I feel like his stuff still shows up
on my feed sometimes. And I feel like he
was saying something as recently as
maybe two weeks ago that he and his
lawyers expect that the entire case is
going to be thrown out. Do we have any
update on the I guess he's probably
going to get into the case
>> messages? The messages are solar
demanding. Destiny talk to a man on
stream or else he's going to leak all
the DMs and videos he shared with Rose.
He also threatens to release Rose's real
age saying you were negligent in
verifying her age even after you joked
about her looking so young that you
would need her ID to make sure she was
really even 18. The only other time I
heard this allegation of Rose being
potentially underage is when I
interviewed Kelly Jean.
>> So he he tweeted like a bit over a week
ago that the Rose girl was an Only Fans
girl. She's not she never she never had
an Only Fans. She was never on any
platform that could have verified her
identity.
>> Why is she known as like a fansly only
fans eirl? She sold nudes via Twitter.
So, it's not it's not that we're trying
to say Destiny's a pedophile. It's that
we're saying Destiny is reckless.
>> I'm gonna be real. She does end up doing
that. It's very much what she would
imply. She'd list all this evidence for
why Destiny should have been suspicious
that she was underage.
>> Also didn't bother to check someone's
like age, right? It's like a
>> she never should she claim she was
underage?
>> She said she was 19 to him. That is
true. But she also said or 18 or 19. I
think she said in messages she was 18
and then turned 19 is most likely the
case. She was also saying, "Oh, I
can't." She was saying to Destiny, I
can't come see you because my parents
wouldn't let me. So, there was like a
lot of like um within these messages
sort of tone indicators that this is a
very young person. But when someone says
only fans, they're spreading a piece of
misinformation in his benefit because if
she did do Only Fans, he could say
>> don't say anything in this
>> known for verifying people's
uh says she's 19. Therefore, it's
reasonable to think that she's 19.
>> I personally feel like that is too
convoluted of an argument. If she lied
about her age, I'm probably not going to
hold him accountable unless I see
evidence that
>> is very obvious that she's lying or he
asked for ID or some [__] and she's
going no.
>> So, he does do that. He kind of he makes
he makes a message saying uh I'll have
Yes, I'll have to find the exact
quotation of what when he mentions when
he mentions identity.
>> Helen never proves this. She links me to
the hacker telling Destiny she was
underage and Destiny replies saying she
told him she was of age selling not safe
for work material.
>> When we started talking, she told me she
was of age. The solo guy on K Farms says
as much. I don't think she was underage.
I don't think she was ever underage.
Well, I mean, except for when she was
underage, but before I ded her
>> when navigating Kiwi forms, the hacker
himself would clarify in a later post to
Rose's knowledge, Destiny did not know
her real age. And even if he did, he did
not make anything about all this stuff.
Like, what? I don't know who this Rose
person is. I am completely in the dark.
>> I don't believe Destiny is a pedophile.
Now, apparently they're DM.
>> This was two months ago.
>> Jokingly asking for ID, commenting on
how young she looks.
>> If I go to a club and I someone
underage, it doesn't matter that I ask
for their age. If they turn out to be
younger, you're still going to get
prosecuted the same way. It's like the
onus is on you. You can
>> I know some I I feel like it's different
policy state to state, but if you're in
like Texas and you're 25 years old and
you sleep with someone and then you find
out after the fact that they're a minor
and then that might like the minor like
showed you like a fake ID, I think you
can still be prosecuted, but I feel like
it it depends on the state.
>> It's called statuto use that as a
defense only to a point especially if
there are there are other reasons to
believe this person could be underage
statuto
>> Rose is the person he sent all the
leaked content to a doesn't require
intent.
This happened to NBA player Josh Giddy
and he got acquitted.
>> No, I don't think you can confirm their
identity. So Ros's boyfriend says she
was 17 at the time and I don't know if
she said she was 18 or 19 at the time of
sending.
>> I I get what you're getting at. I need
more before I'm comfortable going that
far. Kelly wasn't able to have her find
me this message. So I asked Destiny
about it. Did she ever engage with you
or like show you like a site where maybe
it did check for age verification at any
point?
>> Um
the answer is yes. Yes. Yes. like she
active either of I think Tinder to find
some [__] and Tinder does um is an 18 or
older app
>> and Destiny sent messages he had with
Rose and her talking about using Tinder.
I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years so
I don't know. Google says it verifies
age. There needs to be more tangible
evidence right now.
>> This was so [__] Tinder did not
verify age when Destiny was talking
about that [__] It's so dude I
>> case scenario is that he might have lied
to him. And that's the end of the good
news for Destiny. Like yes, congrats.
You're not a pedophile, but the few
extra wins he racks up during his
manifesto are just so insignificant. You
know, yes, Pixie did ask for a comical
amount of money. Her first demand letter
to me was for a a total apology and then
at least $15 million in compensation.
>> Waiting for the fences there. [__] that.
>> Yes. People weaponizing your nudes
against you is wrong.
>> Now in an impossible position.
>> I don't even know what he said there.
>> I don't even like I don't even know what
the precedent is for this kind of thing.
>> It's a start. It's a starting
negotiation. It's your first number in
negotiation. So it's going to be high.
>> Never even heard of a guy. I'm sure this
is not the first time something like
this has ever happened in a world with,
you know, 8 billion people. I do think
that she's entitled to significant
compensation. significant compensation
like you know seven figures minimum I
think that that's perfectly reasonable
but I don't know I I just assume this
would be a case that her lawyers kind of
came up with that number and maybe they
were like figuring that it would be
negotiated down I would assume would be
what would be happening in this position
>> actually you should lowball in all
negotiations it's just polite
>> French point of me was still being
blasted across the internet with family
members including my 13-year-old son
being spanned with explicit videos of me
sometimes even by popular social media
personalities like Justin Mink
the image of Destiny sucking that no
>> W actually this is just her casual you
know reply to tweets uh mine and you
know
>> complaining about is what Pixie and
everyone else you share videos of has to
go through now too. You chose to share
videos of yourself with an e-girl. They
didn't. You made that decision for them.
He acts like this is
>> original. Seven figures and now he's
crawling back. It should cost Destiny
seven figures and now I'm crawling back.
Bro,
>> taken one PR line and accepted it as a
fact without ever digging past the
service. I'm not even sure what you're
referring to there.
>> Everybody signed up for which is not
true.
>> For people who are extremely concerned
with their privacy or material possibly
leaking, I generally just recommend that
we don't record.
>> Pixie lied to and I stopped giving a
after this drama after that. Still
watching Destiny streams. I'm not sure
what you're referring to when it comes
to pixie though there. anything at all.
And there's always some risk that stuff
can leak.
>> What he's not acknowledging is the risk
was him.
>> He doesn't think did horrible [__] in
the situation. Pixie did less horrible
[__] than Destiny. What horrible [__]
did Pixie do? What are you even talking
about?
>> DG chat saying he's not going to sue the
hacker anymore. I'm probably not going
to push it any further since it's just
bad publicity for me now. And Pixie is
forcing us both to waste tens of
thousands of dollars fighting each other
now. Lol. W. So, I'm supposed to care
about the SAB story with Minkx and Kiwi
Farms hosting his nudes when he doesn't
even want to pursue the culprits
anymore.
>> It's incredibly bizarre how many people
are fixated on insisting that I'm not a
victim in this when I was the primary
target of the entire revenge porn
posting. While other people were
undeniably harmed by these lessaks, they
were seen as collateral damage to the
publisher of the material and the
website providing hosting for it in the
goal to attack me. Whether it was
through reputation, monetary harm, or
just some other form of statistic
humiliation.
>> You were the primary target, but the
collateral damage is because of you.
Destiny never acknowledges this. He has
the money to do it all, he's mad at
Pixie, though, because in her story,
he's not the victim. He's the bad guy.
Now, Pixie took him to court. And part
of when you do that is you don't get an
instant public facing apology. I
understand that, but instead of staying
quiet, Destiny claims he had implied
consent because Pix
>> I don't know where you saw any I mean,
like, look, I could be completely out of
the loop here, but Fezy, I'm not I'm not
even sure where you saw that.
Apparently, she was also trading around
nudes like Destiny without perms. I I I
haven't heard anything about that. She
sent a video of herself with
>> So that's not true. So this claimed all
the way back then. Destiny did not
contest the idea that she had permission
until way late. It had been months of
this [__] Before Destiny started
actually contesting the ship permission,
it was always known that she was sending
to a boyfriend
>> with another guy before.
>> With that out of the way, conversations
guessing as to whether or not any of the
leaked material is consentually shared.
>> There's even there's even conversations.
There's a there's a specific DM that is
leaked where Destiny is talking to Pixie
after Lav has public a few years ago
after Lav has publicly stated that Pixie
and Destiny had sex where Destiny and
Pixie are speaking about how Lav could
possibly know. Obviously, Destiny told
her and we know that now,
but Pixie's like, "How how does Lav
know? How does Lav know about this?"
And we don't see Destiny's DMs because
he's deleted his side. But we see
Pixie's response where she says, "Um, no
one knows on my side either except
obviously my boyfriend or something like
that."
So, it's pretty clear, they agree that
no one on, and this is ages after the me
video has been sent to Rose, too, that
nobody could possibly know they had sex
because only their significant others
could know about it. And obviously,
their significant others would know
about it. Why is it obvious? Well,
because they discussed they had
discussed that they would tell and
share. topic of discussion. Following
the initial leaks, Pixie would send
messages to people to tell them that she
had never sent videos of other people to
me before, and she portrayed herself in
her Substack as I was the first person
to ever suggest this to her.
>> She responded to his manifesto, and I
assume that um Willie Mack is going to
address that in this video.
>> I was the first person she ever recorded
material with. Um I know that she's
messaged people with stuff like this.
>> To me, her lying about the nature of
their sexing would only make her a
hypocrite. It doesn't make sharing other
people's nudes without their
>> Dixie lied in her substack that she was
sexually inexperienced prior to Destiny
despite her sending porn of herself with
other people to Destiny prior to them
filming. That doesn't mean that
someone's super experienced. What do you
mean? What do you Wait, what? What is
that logic? Because if somebody if
somebody engaged in like exchanging of
nudes previous to another sexual
relationship, that means that they can't
be inexperienced. What if they only like
one or two partners? Like I would say
someone who has only had like two
partners, I would still call that like
sexually inexperience or like you know,
if you haven't had long-term
relationships with a sexual
relationship, you know, like maybe if
you slept with a couple people, but they
weren't like longterm, I would still say
that that's pretty inexperienced. Um
>> that's okay. He doesn't even know she
didn't have consent.
>> Pixie was comfortable sending me videos
of her and other identifiable men with
them even having saved videos on their
own phones. Some guy, if you're
interested, sure, I'll send them to you
when I get them. At no point in any of
these conversations did Pixie ever
mention having explicit consent from any
of these other men to share these videos
with me. I have no way of contacting
them today to find out she did. All this
to say the day.
>> So here he just casters. She says, "Oh
yeah, I can't I can't know whether these
people consented after he's already
cried about
people doing that with his phone
recorded Grinder audio hookup
recordings.
[__] you know the pock the pocket
recordings of [__] Grinder hookups.
He was [__] crying about people
saying, "Oh, you know, it kind of seems
like because this phone's in your pocket
as you walk up to the apartment
and then you you get get sucked off by
this guy and then take your phone out
while still in the apartment and turn
off a recording." It kind of seems like
basically what happened here is you
snuck your phone in while recording
without consent. And Destiny freaked the
[__] out and was like, "How dare you say
that? Like, how could I even prove that?
How dare it's so disgusting people would
say this about people trying to make me
prove this." And they did the exact same
[__] to Pixie. The exact same [__]
>> After you lose your virginity, you're a
sex god. Exactly. Yeah.
>> That's exactly what that logic is. stood
by both sides of the situation.
>> What do you mean? How? He's assuming
that she didn't have permission from
this guy when he has no reason to
believe that. In what world does this
give him consent to share her nudes?
This makes no sense. This was the
manifestos to end all manifestos. And
it's literally debunked by his own logic
in our interview. One of the lease on
Kiwi Farms was a [__]
>> I don't know if he is going to respond,
but but uh Pixie did directly address
that by saying she did have consent with
her previous partner to send videos
before
>> recording that happened with a guy he
met on Grinder. And the recording
allegedly starts before he walks into
the guy's apartment. And if you read the
DM of Destiny sharing the video to Rose,
he says, "This is just the end. I get
audio scuffed because my phone was in my
pocket." Implying that the video was
secretly recorded. Here is Destiny's
defense.
>> Oh, why would he have it in his pocket
and not record the thing with the video?
It must be because he's not letting the
person know. He's secretly recording.
>> Yeah, sure. So, like, so here, okay, so
let me preface this by saying the only
reason that recording you're talking
about is leaked is because I think all
the girls have started messaging
afterwards like, "Oh my god, this might
be blah blah." I think that group of
people started leaking [__] to Kiwi
Farms of hookups that nobody is alleging
anything wrong has happened. So, it's
very annoying. And that what you're
talking about like literally audio that
entire
>> No, there was one person specifically
that was alleging that they were that
they had been shown evidence in private
that they were recorded without their
consent. I mean, I don't know what he's
talking about there.
>> The thing is now just public for no
reason. So, that is revenge porn of me
posted. Then everything spread because
it's epic and hilarious. Okay,
>> that makes uh in all honesty, what's
probably going to happen here is the
case will be dropped or settled. Then
this will fade into internet obscurity
until it gets brought up years from now
as a one-off insult in the middle of a
debate. I mean, Bosch literally accepted
accidentally showed his underage cartoon
porn and his career is fine. I mean, I
don't I don't disagree with what you're
saying at all. I think that's very
likely what is going to happen.
>> Makes sense to me. If the guy involved
isn't claiming wrongdoing at this point,
who cares? It's irrelevant.
>> That being said, generally with guys on
writer, there are guys that I struggle
with and not be like, "Hey, are you
happy? Are you comfortable recording
stuff? You want to do a video?" Most
guys are comfortable with video. A
couple have been obviously, hence my
leaks. Um, some guys are like, "Okay,
cool." You know, like audio is fine. I
don't care as long as you can't identify
it. That's why I don't even know how
many of my things have been pretty
obvious the guy can like see my phone or
whatever. I think for that particular
one, I think this recording was like in
5 years or four years ago. I don't
remember. For this particular guy, um,
he said, "Listen, if you want to record
your audio, that's fine, but like don't
pull your phone out. I don't want to see
it. I'm like really paranoid about my
face getting recorded." I'm like, "Okay,
I'll just call you start before I come
to the apartment." Like, that's fine.
Just like don't pull your phone out
because that would like it's like he's
just like paranoid about like me
recording space. Like, okay, that was
the story for that dude. But it's really
gay talk about this because one, it's
actually gay. But then two, also
nobody's like any wrong for any of
these. So, it's like really weird that
because other people are literally
leaking in front of your phone and
they're having to like describe like how
works consent like nobody's even making
allegation of this. Like I don't know if
this is going to turn into like every
single like I don't know if people are
going to start leaking every single
video.
>> I feel like that's not true. I feel like
people did did specifically allege that
they were recorded without consent
>> recorded and like was it more than one
this is cringing gross and weird but
that's why yeah I mean that's for that
if he's not complaining about it then
how do we know
>> with that same logic?
>> Well Cherry came forward
>> entirely debunks Destiny's implied
consent defense for Pixie because that
guy's not out here complaining. In fact,
Pixie claims she had consent from him.
Actual consent to send those videos sent
defense for Pixie because that guy's not
out here complaining. In fact, Pixie.
>> Yeah, this is the DM I was talking
about. It's here. No one knows either on
my end except my exB. I trust you
believe you. Do you think they're going
to make up a bunch of stuff? That's her
talking to Destiny.
>> Claims she had consent from him. Actual
consent to send those videos. He writes,
"This is false. This guy was my ex who
consented to share."
>> Oh, he did. He did show her response to
>> recording random one night stands. I'll
be real. The DMs she links don't really
prove anything, but then a guy named Tom
as
>> well. No, they kind of they kind of do
actually. This is just Willie Mack being
[__] [__] So obviously this from
March 5th, 2023. She says no one knows
either on my end. So that obviously
implies like the pretty much the only
thing Destiny can be saying in that
previous message. The only thing it's
reasonable to assume Destiny is saying
is something like no one on knows no one
knows on my end except Molina. pretty
much the only reasonable thing he could
be saying in that previous DM, which is
obviously a total [__] lie because he
told Lav and he'd shared the video
around. And not only that, but it's
communicating here that her ex-boyfriend
would know they had sex. It follows from
that that it's reasonable that Pixie
would have uh uh told told Destiny that
stuff was being shared with her
ex-boyfriend. So, we can't know that
part for sure. That's less strong than
the other part, but it is there saying,
"Except my XBF." Destiny knew her
ex-boyfriend would know about them
having sex at the very minimum. So, the
idea that Destiny now is suddenly acting
like like how would this is the
conversation Destiny wants you to
believe happened. He had a conversation
with Pixie where they both said their
partners would be the only ones who knew
they had sex. Destiny told Pixie that
Molina would be getting videos, but
Pixie in that moment did not say
anything to Destiny about her boyfriend,
her significant other getting videos.
So, this is for some reason a a purely
asymmetrical agreement in this
conversation that they both agree
happened. Just Destiny says, "No, it was
an asymmetrical agreement."
That sounds [__] That sounds
[__] No, the far more reasonable
explanation is that you both agreed.
send significant others.
He did show her response to
>> recording random one night stands. I'll
be real. The DMs she links don't really
prove anything. But then a guy named Tom
asked, "The question is whether or not
you had consent to share the video." She
clarifies, "I had consent. I believe the
courts will exonerate me." So Destiny's
entire defense of calling Pixie a
hypocrite is debunked by his own logic.
It comes off as incredibly desperate.
She says, "Destiny, you're now using
intimate details of my life against me.
I need you to stop. You've already
shared some of my most intimate moments
for the world to see. Why are you
forcing me to share more?" Another
defense Destiny alludes to in his
response is that he was part of the
scandalous videos. Therefore, that makes
it okay to share. In a way, Pixie is
kind of like the perfect victim. It
seems like she shared news with you. You
shared them with a third party. That
party got hacked. It all leaks.
>> By the way, I want a couple things. Hold
on just real quick. I never sent nudes
that somebody sent me to somebody else.
I've never done that before. It's really
weird. I've only ever sent videos that
I'm in. Sometimes videos with other
people, but like in terms of me sending
anything to the person. It's like it's
because I'm in it, not because somebody
else is in it. Just to be super clear on
that. To some people that doesn't
matter. For other people, it's like a
really big point because when that post
was written for Pixie, it was written
like he wanted to show my body off and
blah blah blah. That's not true at all.
She's not even
>> Well, I mean, she's obviously like a
part of that video. She's like an
essential part of that video. So like
even even if the king is like here's me
in a sexual position. You still need a
partner to be in that position
>> video. That doesn't make any difference
to me. He violated the person's trust in
sharing the intimate video in the first
place, him being part of it.
>> Um Edmard said after the allegation from
Cherry, there was also a screenshot of a
G Drive link that was apparently
recording of I don't know about all
that. Like if the if the court case
continues and there's there's there's
more filings. I'm sure you know we'll
have a lot more details at some point.
>> Not changes nothing. It seems like the
only reason he would bring this up is if
he felt like there was some sort of
legal distinction. talking about
anything that's related like specific
question and then you say if it can be
allowed in the video or not because if
not I'm not trying to anybody. Okay.
>> Um you very much clarified your part of
these videos too. Guess what I'm
wondering is does that make a legal
distinction? Is that
>> I'm wondering what I want to hide in
this video.
>> Um there's two parts that are really
important that I'm okay comfortable
about. So for one part of legal
distinction here and this is annoying
because it applies legally and it
applies morally I think and I guess it
applies to the PR angle too. Like I have
never ever in my life like
>> probably best to wait for the court
case. I mean I'm I I I'm going to wait
for more details before coming to like
very specific determinations but there
is enough in the public fear at this
point to have certain opinions. Um
>> uh oh this might be it.
>> Try to like um show somebody.
>> Does he expand on that at any point?
What opinions can you have from public
information
>> by like sharing like a revenge? Like for
example, it seems pretty open and shut
that he shared nudes with someone
without their permission. Like he's he's
himself seemingly has admitted to that
multiple times.
>> So in private correspondence,
>> this is this is probably why it was
private because he says this. He says
this
>> uh so this I feel like you're you're
entitled to have an informed opinion at
that at that point. Now are there going
to be like granular details that maybe
change change kind of this thing or that
thing on the margins of the story? Yeah,
like yeah, maybe probably right. But the
core of the allegation remains pretty
like rock solid. Like somebody
woke up one day and images of them of a
sexually explicit nature were being
passed around to like thousands of
perhaps millions of people and they had
never intended those videos to be to be
public. I'm speaking about Pixie Pixie
in this spot. And
yeah, there's enough info to feel like
she was like certainly victimized would
be a good word for it, right?
>> Of them.
>> You're talking about like the
maliciousness of it, right?
>> Yeah. Because now there would be like
now they're that's the distinction that
they're kind of going into now. like
Destiny wants there to be this really
big distinction because he didn't intend
for these pictures to to come out. He
didn't intend for this harm to befall
Pix Pixie. Um seems like he's really
counting on that being like uh
exonerating in some way. But and there
is a difference like there's a spectrum
of wrongdoing and so like on one
spectrum maliciously like knowingly
sending someone nudes out in order to
humiliate them and intentionally violate
their trust in a way like to to like
direct harm their way that would be much
worse than what is going on here. But I
I I don't think that the fact that
there's something worse that's possible
makes what already happened here
necessarily any better. It's okay. Yeah.
It's, you know, that's worse in
comparison, but but there's still a lot
of damage here, right?
>> Some people say, "Oh, I was trying like
humiliate, you know, like I try to
humiliate." No, never mind. My life have
I done that. I would never do. Well, I
mean, there was um 14 years ago with a
one blue tea girl. That was shitty to
everybody for sure.
>> Blue tea was somebody that Destiny
sucked in and then shared their nudes
with his buddies. At least according to
Ryan Beard's video, an old forum post I
could find online.
>> Just thought it would be funny to share
this woman's private nudes with his
friends and joke about how hideous her
face is compared to her beautiful body.
And he also insulted her because he
thought she looked like Shrek. So he
shared a woman's private nudes without
consent for the purpose of degrading
her. In response, Blue Te hacked
Destiny's Twitter and tweeted out
pictures of his dick.
>> She's cute as a man. That was a [__]
whatever like that. But like I've never
like I'm never like sending videos or
pictures like, "Oh yeah, this is going
to humiliate this person." Like that's
just insane. Okay, that claim is insane.
Nothing. That's
>> Didn't Pixie openly speculate that
Destiny did it on purpose and malicious
maliciously did it to her? She did. And
I feel like a lot of people were giving
her [__] for that because I mean I don't
think there's strong evidence that
that's what he did. I don't think
there's any evidence that he did it
maliciously to harm her. But when you've
experienced harm on that scale like she
did, it's easy to
>> I'm sorry. Destiny has acknowledged how
many times you if you send something to
a couple people online, you know it's
going to leak. At what point do you just
really you just say, "Okay, dude, you
knew what you were doing fully and you
seem to get off on leaking these details
and having [__] come out and be exposed
and you go and when [__] leaks, you go
and refer other girls to the public
posts." So, like it just comes off like
this guy at minimum does not give a [__]
possibly deliberately engages this way.
Like that's that seems very reasonable
to me to assume he deliberately engaged
in in in this way. Why somebody would
speculate that that's what happened. You
know what I mean? Like it's like if you
put yourself in her shoes and then try
to imagine going through that experience
of of feeling violated in such a public
way, then you're going to your brain's
going to go to places like that. I feel
like that that's like a seems like a
pretty human reaction, right?
>> Leak from my logs implies that. I've
never had a conversation with leak that
implies that I would ever do that to
something like that's just wild. Um
yeah,
>> just just to be clear these
>> cuz I have not seen the videos. Just to
be clear, there is videos of Pixies that
were leaked. She was not aware that you
shared these with Rose.
>> Um I can't speak to that. I will clarify
one thing. Fair enough.
>> Um it's video. It's one singular video.
>> The blue tea drop happened in 2012. And
if he was caught shar Well, I I mean I
don't Does anybody dispute that that
happened at this point? Is anybody
denying that that's what happened at
this point? The distinction between one
video or several videos doesn't really
seem material to come to a conclusion
about this or to have an opinion about
it. Um,
>> nudes then and he was called sharing
nudes.
>> Does any party dispute or deny that
videos of Pixie were released without
her? I don't I don't know if anyone has
denied that now. That means he was
probably sharing nud all the years in
between. In fact, right after the Pixie
drama blew up in January, DMs from a
girl named Hannah showing Destiny
seemingly still trying to share news
saying, "Oof, I guess now that some
stuff is
>> I understand her perspective. I feel bad
for her doing that could sink her case."
I mean, I'm not up to date on Florida
law, so I don't think I can apply one
way or the other there, but I don't know
if that would sink her case, right? LMO,
if you want videos of me eating, I got
them. She laughs and then says, "Haha,
he might be limited in what he might say
because of the legal stuff." Of course.
>> Oh, don't show me that. Those are super
private. I can't imagine how it feels
having something so private be public,
even if you were Polly. Now, this is
crazy because behind the scenes, Pixie
is saying he ruined her life and is
posting a suicide note to him less than
a month earlier. And if he was still
doing this, that is psychotic behavior.
Now, Destiny would claim that this was
all just edgy jokes that took place when
they were flirting. He deleted his DM.
So, it's hard to understand the full
context.
>> This is like half on the record. I don't
figure
>> Is it safe to say that no matter the
outcome of this, Destiny will probably
up again? I mean, I don't I can't speak
to his moral journey. people I you know
I know a lot of people that are that
engage in sort of self-destructive
behavior at various points in their
lives and then they turn things around.
It's possible. It's possible that that
people turn things around. And according
to him, a lot of his uh his viewers,
destined viewers, he he already has like
this is not behavior that he
>> except you literally watching a video
where he's he's spuring out calling for
violence and doxing people, right?
>> He he does anymore is what I've heard
from.
>> Why do we not care about anything bad
empanada does? Like this is the thing,
right? Is these people these wretched
[__] like Hutch want to virtue signal
endlessly about [__] bad empanada,
dude. because he what I think the worst
thing I've heard about bad empanada
doing is is loan box stuff. Apparently
some of his fans got together and [__]
with his university or some [__] I I
don't that's like the worst stuff. And
then the [__] they pull out is like he
threatened to kill aristocracy by making
a joke about uh the terrorists from a
video game. He he called a hitman on
Vosch by posting an address from the
show Beverly Hills 90210.
He he uh tried to get Destiny and Loader
Box killed in Israel by putting out a
tweet that says, "Lion's Den, you could
do the funniest thing right now."
It's like and then you go look at
Destiny and this guy is actually like a
depraved, despicable,
worthless,
vindictive,
like non-stop doxing, calling for
violence,
con, you know, violating consent of men
and women,
just a just a total rep probate through
and through. And they're just like, "Oh,
well, you know, some stuff was
misunderstood." I feel like some stuff
was misunderstood,
bro. How can anyone take them seriously?
Hold on. A lot of dark humor. Okay. I've
made jokes about a lot of things that
people come back and try to make me like
a sociopath. Like me and my kid's mom
used to be physically abusive towards
each other. Um, and some people will
link clips of me talking about it 10
years ago. He said he used to choke out
his ex.
>> Even if he went down to hold her to stop
throwing [__] instead of hitting her,
I'm almost 100% sure everyone would be
saying the same [__] He had to leave
her. He's going, "Yeah, I
>> was he interacting with while he was
driving?" Jesus Christ.
>> I do. I wish I would film my [__] with
Rachel. I wouldn't have any because you
guys are probably think I'm abuser, too.
Guarantee because you better believe I
had to choke her out of your times. That
got crazy. Hell yeah, dude. And I
guarantee that everybody here probably
think I'm a crazy physical abuser, too.
Sure.
>> Oh, he's parked. Okay. Jesus,
>> I'm joking when I say the [__] Or
people say, "Oh, Destiny's
>> joking." Haha. JK.
JK about choking up my ex-wife.
Something that I've stated on numerous
occasions and defended.
>> Friend committed suicide when he was 20
because he jokes about crazy shot. But
also, um, this so me and Hannah had been
chatting maybe for on and off for like a
year. had never been sexual ever, not
even remotely sexual in anything ever.
And that
>> I meant her accusing Destiny of doing it
maliciously. She could be compromising
her own case. Destiny has made it clear
that it was not malicious. I don't know
how that would compromise her case, but
I'm not a [__] lawyer, so maybe
you're more
>> as of like
>> maybe you're more like educated on the
on the uh like the implications of that,
>> not the dates on the message. Was it
like two months ago or three months ago?
>> I think she makes I think she makes a
joke um with about Merc. Oh, and she
deleted all those messages. Very clever.
But she makes a joke about M. Oh god, I
just that crazy girl M arguing with her
and then she's like just so you know, I
would
>> Destiny trashed all his connections
because they didn't like what happened.
What's like like I feel like ABA is a
really good example of of like how your
behavior can can ripple out and and and
and affects like other relationships
too. It's like put yourselves in the
shoes of any creator that is you know
that rely on themselves as their as
their brand to make money like your
livelihood. There are just practical I
put aside the moral associating with
this person or that person which is an
entirely separate conversation. When
you're a creator you are the person that
is in charge of like all of your income
and all of your income revolves around
your appeal. And if you associate with
someone who is mired in this kind of
controversy, there could be serious like
material consequences for you. And so
like I feel like Destiny just put
everybody that he associated with in a
really tricky situation. Of course, I
mean this happened 5 years ago,
whatever, but like nonetheless, like
we're still accountable to the things
that we did years ago. And um unless
you're like a good friend of his,
there's just like there are so many
legitimate reasons to put space between
you and any creator that is embroiled in
that kind of controversy. That's just
something like practical consideration.
I mean again we could that's just the
moral the moral argument is completely
different. a totally different subject,
but that's a question that like every
creator has to ask themselves because
like in this like social media ecosystem
there are these vast interconnected
networks and so we're all like appearing
on each other's stuff and so you make
these associations and a lot of the
times you make these associations you
don't really know much about the person
that you're having a conversation with.
You know, like maybe you saw a video of
theirs and you really liked it and
you're like, "Hey, do you want to
collaborate? Let's talk about
something." You're not doing a like a
private detective. You're not doing like
a background check on everybody that you
have conversations with. And so when
stuff like this comes up and Destiny is
not the first example of this. Um this
this is like something when you do
content creation and you don't live on
an island and you collaborate with other
people this is just something that is
going to happen over and over and over
and over and over again like you know
Destiny is not going to be the last
person that I've collaborated with where
there's there's going to be some stuff
that comes out that paints them in a
really poor light or creates some kind
of controversy. I'll have to make the
same decision then that I do and I make
different decisions based on different
circumstances or whatever. Um but yeah
>> never ever out any of your advances lol.
And so like oh that's a great life I
guess. And I think our next conversation
could be could be not so Aerodite. Who
knows?
>> She makes a reference to something about
like videos or like oh like or something
sexual
>> my money is on Aerodite. My money is on
Aerodite. I'm going to be real.
>> And I think I make the joke. I'm like
hey listen they're still on farms. Lol.
Which is true but like that was the
extent of my message.
>> Like everybody I mean that's yeah I
guess I guess you're right. Yeah. I
guess it's that's true to a certain
extent for people that even don't do
content creation. You know like people
just that have normally 9 to5 jobs have
to think about these things as well. So
it's just it's just there's a public
element to content creation that adds a
that adds a layer of complexity that can
change the calculus. Um, yeah,
>> they're wrong here because they both
deleted messages. And to be fair to him,
he didn't send anything. But if she said
yes to the offer, would he have? That's
up to you to decide.
>> Would never I don't want to um I'm not
going to drag any of these people, okay?
But I will say like I don't want to do
any I'm not going to do anything. Like
there are so many there are so many.
>> When was this interview, by the way? Cuz
it seems like this interview happened in
the last like month. It seems like this
is a recent interview, right?
>> That send messages. I'm not even sure.
Like there's so many people that send me
like this when everything was leaking.
Okay.
>> I don't know. I think the moral and
business association argument should be
one and the same. I mean, they're
linked, right? But they're they're kind
of separate, but they're linked, right?
Yeah.
>> Uh hold on. You just sent me something.
>> When are the Hutch leaks coming? Listen,
if any [__] and this isn't me just like
doing like a holier than now thing, like
I mean, I've definitely done some [__]
that I would be judged harshly for by
the internet when I was like in my 20s
or maybe 30s or whatever. That's the
case for everybody, but I've been
shacked up with the same woman for 10
years now. My life is very boring, and I
love that my life is very boring. It's
incredible. If my [__] hacks now, the
biggest risk to me would be just what a
nerd I am. Like people looking at my uh
people looking at my YouTube history and
watching me watch like MCU film rumor
videos five times a day. That that'd be
kind of embarrassing. Like if that I'll
tell you guys whatever, but like
41-year-old dude watching like MCU rumor
movie rumor YouTube videos every five
times a day every day. And the the other
thing too is I've seen many I have seen
many a downfall of many a creator
because of leaked stuff. I started
seeing that really early on. Uh like it
took a minute for it to start happening.
Like YouTube celebrity or whatever was a
novel thing still back in 2009 and there
just there just wasn't a whole lot of
this kind of drama that happened. But I
remember back in 2011 thinking to
myself, wait a second, like there's a
lot more kind of famous YouTubers. And
so the odds of there being something
like a sex scandal, it's like when are
we going to have our first YouTube sex
scandal is what I remember thinking
about like in 2011. I was like it's
going to happen at some point. And then
I think like the first one was this. You
remember the Shay Tards? You guys
remember the I mean I fly that was a
different kind of thing. That wasn't
really like a leak. But do you guys
remember the Shay like Shay Carl?
Remember that? And then he called his
kids like little tards. That was crazy
in retrospect. Like his name was Shay
Carl and he called his family the
Shaytards and then there was like he
gave his kids like little [__] names. So
it was like baby [__] It was crazy.
Like and I remember thinking in the
beginning I was like oh this is kind of
And then I remember thinking like
actually this kind of dark. Like imagine
growing up as a kid and your [__] is
just broadcast out to the internet in
daily vlogs. Like I just remember
thinking like wait I don't think I like
this. Jake Carl was this guy who was
like one of the OG vloggers and um he
was I think it was a Mormon. I I don't
think Faith
>> Oh, man. This is a great This is a great
[__] tangent. I got to say
>> I didn't know that there's
>> he spoke about Destiny for about 20
seconds in this [__] video again. If
something like that had happened to me
if you guys remember.
>> Does he not even finish the Willy Mac
video? He doesn't. He jacked his [__] on
on
and then he walks over and he and then
he realizes a mistake and he's like,
"Oh, hey guys."
Crazy, you know? So, like, so when that
happened, I'm like, "Okay, that's a
lesson. Never beat your [__] on the same
computer that you use for work." From
that point on, I did not beat my [__]
using my work computer. I keep it
completely segregated. And then for like
private DM stuff, you know, like I've
seen so many private DMs leak when I DM
anybody. I mean, there's some DMs that
would come out that would maybe be like
a little embarrassing because it's just
not something that I would want to talk
about in public. But when when it comes
to private DMs, I'm just like, let's
just proceed under the assumption that
all of our correspondents will come out
in a court hearing at some point in my
life. And so, I don't always do that,
right? Like, I'm not perfect, but like
as a general rule of thumb, there are
just certain things that I don't do
because I've seen uh because I've seen
creators lose their entire careers
because evidence of a crime in messages.
Hear you loud and clear, Hajj. Great
advice. Great advice.